each year millions of people fulfill a
dream to visit Hollywood and many of
them walk in the concrete footsteps of
some of the greatest actors of all time
right next door at the Grauman's Chinese
Theatre tonight we honor ten actors and
actresses one of whom is doing a
fabulous job hosting tonight thank you
you're welcome good to have all left
their own indelible impressions on
history with their great performances
this year please welcome last year's
Academy Award winner for Best Actor and
a nominee again this year
Jeff Bridges
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's my honor this evening to present
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a leading role and that
throughout your magnificent career you
have always imbued your characters with
strength and humanity that's impossible
to turn away from and this time around
is no exception with your fierce and
fragile performance in The Kids Are
Alright Annette Bening
Nicole you have delivered stunning
performances year after year distilling
your characters reality to their purest
form and what is being called your best
performance today that reality is as
painful as your vivid portrayal of Becca
in awe is awe-inspiring in rabbit-hole
Nicole Kidman
jennipher the depth you bring to the
screen is well beyond your years I speak
for everyone watching tonight when I say
I look forward to watching your long
career unfold especially after your
astounding breakthrough performance in
Winter's Bone Jennifer Lawrence
Natalie you have won over film devotees
of all generations with the range of
characters you make your own and no
matter the role your love for the craft
always shines through
but perhaps never more than this year as
Nina in Black Swan Natalie Portman
Michelle your vulnerability is truthful
brave and raw
no matter the part you elicit the
audience's empathy with a grounded open
heart and this year you did so once
again with your extraordinary work in
Blue Valentine Michelle Williams
and the Oscar goes to Natalie Portman
black song
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Natalie Portman
her first Oscar nomination was for
Supporting Actress in closer
[Applause]
thank you
so much
uh thank you so much to the Academy this
is insane um and I I truly sincerely
wish that the prize tonight was to get
to work with my fellow nominees I'm so
in awe of you um I am so grateful to get
to do the job that I do I love it so
much I want to thank my parents um were
right there first and foremost for
giving me my life and for giving me the
opportunity to work from such an early
age and showing me everyday how to be a
good human being by example and um I
want to thank my team who works with me
every day
aleem because she should my manager for
18 years and my agents Kevin Havana and
everyone at CAA Bruna and tomorrow died
II my friends who are everything to me
no matter what's going on in my career
um and everyone who's ever hired me
lupus on who gave him first job when I
was 11 years old
um Mike Nichols who has been my hero and
my champion for the past decade and now
Darren Aronofsky you are a fearless
leader at visionary I am blessed to have
just gotten to get to work with you
every day for the period of time we did
so many people helped me prepare for
this role Mary Helen Bauer spent a year
with me training me Michelle Rodriguez
and Curt Froman and Olga is cricket's
Coast Witzke sorry marina stavis kaya
and my beautiful love Benjamin millipede
who choreographed the film and has now
given me my most important role of my
life and also there are people on films
that no one ever talks about that are
your heart and soul every day Margene
Jordy who did my hair and makeup Nicki
who dressed me and Kate and Laura Mele
Vee who designs the beautiful ballet
costumes
Joe Reedy are an incredible ad first ad
and our camera operators JC and Steve
you gave me so much soul behind the
camera every day and you gave me all of
your energy most importantly my my
family my friends and my love thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]